scarcely bigger than a thumbnail this
unusual frog attracted Charles Darwin's
attention back in the mid 19th century
now it's named after him Darwin's frog
it lives in Patagonia for instance here
in huilo huilo Nature Reserve in
southern Chile Darwin's frogs are an
endangered species biologist Veronica
Toledo tracks them down in the forests
of Patagonia the chytrid fungus is the
main threat to amphibians around the
world so we take certain precautions
when we enter their habitat we handle
Darwin's frogs only when wearing gloves
because we don't know whether and which
of them are infected and we use
different gloves for each frog do you
want a guarantee the chytrid fungus is
responsible for a worldwide decrease in
amphibians it also threatens Darwin's
frog although only two affected frogs
have been found here in the reserve
Darwin's frogs play dead when they sense
danger it's easy for her to identify
them by the individual black and white
markings on their underside after
examining in the frogs she sets them
free again 500 kilometers farther north
the University in the city of concepción
is trying to ensure the survival of the
species in another way veterinarian
Carlos Barrientos stone also is raising
the amphibians in a breeding station
several hundred frogs live in the cool
moist surroundings these animals prefer
sometimes alone sometimes in pairs to
produce young but the vet isn't putting
his trust in the breeding station alone
some of the frogs will soon be going on
a long journey they'll be sent by plane
to several zoos in Europe the ideas for
the frogs to reproduce outside the
country to give us another option if we
have any emergencies or trouble here
the zoos in Europe can ensure the
survival of the species if all goes well
these Darwin's frogs will find new homes
in zoos in Berlin and Leipzig among
others it's an important step towards
saving this unique species from
extinction